Film Courage: Do you feel it's a director's job to be
on set before everyone else, Choice? Choice Skinner, actor, director, instructor:  Oh
absolutely. I believe that if you set the
precedent everyone will follow. The
director you know people always think
that producers fix problems. Directors
prevent problems and fixes them as well.
Especially if you're director/producer
or director/producer/writer, I've got to be
there first. I have to be the one to get
the energy up I got to make sure
sometimes I'll I'll drink a monster on
the way to say if it's been a long shoot
I'm pumped up I find a way to make
everything feel good for everybody you
know everyone's there to create
something they're all there to to share
their gifts as Patrick my other friend
says they're there to share their gifts
and your job is to make sure that they
have a fertile ground in which to plant
great seeds and so yeah I'm there I'm
usually there first and sometimes the
last to leave unless it's a project
where they got to take everything down I
got an early call time you know I got to
leave and get some sleep
or watch the aliens and then get up and
start the process all over again
what are five skills you think a
director should have every director
should if they don't have them work on
them the skill communicating with actors
is number one which is why you know some
of the best actors some of the best
directors were actors right so the skill
of the skill of directing actors the
skill of talking to actors is one making
a tremendous shot list and being
flexible with being able to leave that
shot list it's - the shot is never more
important than the actors or the crew
never and I've been on sets where people
feel like oh well I got to get my shot
again oh you have to take care of your
people because you're a leader that was
- number three I would say is a work
environment that is fun uplifting
inspiring even if it's a drama even if
it's a drama I mean it's easy for a
comedy or it's easy for an action film
for everybody to get pumped up and to
feel you know a certain way but it's
important and imperative that you may
feel where people want to come to the
set and with a drama that's even more of
a reason why you want to have that
lifted experience number four the skill
of listening I learned that that it's
important to listen to people because
sometimes sometimes you may have an idea
and what you want and the DP or your
producers or the actors may have a
different way and it's important to
listen to them because they may be
telling you something that you won't
find out until post and then you go oh
that's a good reason that was a good
reason and number five the skill of
letting go if it's not meant to be it's
not meant to be now that's contrary to
knowing that it doesn't matter what it
takes to get it done okay without people
being compromised but at the same time
it's the thing of saying okay there's a
reason why it's not happening let it go
it's different than saying it you know
it's not impossible anything's possible
I can get it done don't say no because
know is never done anything for anybody
but when it comes to saying okay this is
it that you know let it go instead of
wasting you know 20 minutes talking
about a shot with an actor just say okay
listen no words why don't you go ahead
and give me that and then give me this
so now I have two choices cuz then that
goes back to the listening thing when I
go on to post then I got alright okay
I'll use that one it's dead letting go
versus what you always hear about is
these great creative geniuses
entrepreneurs they're so driven they're
obsessed can you still be all of that
and at some point let go
passive-aggressive energy is part of
that personality thing that I mentioned
about this industry no one has to be
overtly authoritative you never have to
force somebody to do something
if if it's something that needs to be
done we all know we all show it we're
all there we say okay this needs to be
done we all understand that you hire
people according to that you would hope
that everybody shows up that everybody
does their part
you can't Bank on someone's life being
upside down and they're not in it and
they do a shoddy job but guess what it
falls on you to fix it to make it right
I never had that issue because I'm
always I'm always in the mindset of I'm
good at so many things
I don't know everything but everything I
know I know well and I make that happen
because of the fact that you never know
what will be the wink weak link and what
you're doing so all you can do is hope
that everybody shows up and and
everybody pulls through and and just
understand that you can't make anybody
to it you can't you yeah I don't care
how it throw the tail of a person you
are the more you argue with someone the
less they're likely they're gonna want
to do it I mean it's just the way it is
that's who we are as human beings you
talked about seeds fertile soil
something it's interesting because last
night driving home I heard that on the
radio and the guy was talking about what
he thought was going to be this great
thing turned out that it was bad and
what he didn't realize is the analogy or
maybe it's a parable about trying to
plant seeds and soil that's not been so
that's not fertile that's almost like
it's a bunch of rocks yep unmet
expectations breeds depression unmet
expectations breeds depression which
basically means this I may have thought
that planting the seed was gonna bring
forth a lot a great harvest but it may
have not been for that seed to go there
and the expectation that I had on it is
gonna be very very very unmet it's gonna
be sad for me because I'm expecting I'm
putting a lot you know people always say
don't cast all your irons in the fire or
you know it's the same thing you have to
be mindful and knowing that sometimes
things don't go that way and you have to
be adjustable you have to be flexible
and you
- no in the end is gonna work out I mean
that's to me that's a faith thing that's
the thing to understand the faith that's
the thing of understanding purpose
understanding Providence understanding
that it's already worked out before you
even embarked on it it's gonna be okay
but can you accept that it didn't work
out can you accept that because of it
worked out that there's a lesson in that
for you down the road that's gonna teach
you something even more like I go back
to my music career it didn't work out
right I was great I was amazing I was
talented you know there was opportunity
but it didn't work out if I wasn't able
say for instance it got to the point
where I was so upset about that I did
something erratic because it didn't work
out I would have never gotten this far
to know that there were other glorious
things that were gonna open up for me
and I look back at that of course we
have regrets who doesn't have regrets
right that's part of life you should
have regrets because regrets help you to
understand not to make the same mistakes
but at least an understanding that you
know okay
I sold a seed I plant the seed but it
didn't happen well let me just take that
seed
dig it up it's still you still got the
seed then put it over here and maybe
it'll grow I don't know we'll see what
happens just got to keep going
you